good morning
afternoon it is 2:30 I'm going to open
the
subcommittee hearing for House Bill 1025
relative to disorderly
conduct and are are you here for for
this
bill well we don't have the sponsor it
doesn't look like any anybody else is
here did you have something you would
like to to say about the bill we're
happy to hear what you have to
say okay thank you for
sharing so my question with this is um
the bill reab repeals the prohibition
against directing at another person in
public place of seen derisive or
offensive words which are likely to
provoke a violent reaction so if
somebody says something in somebody's
face and somebody punches him in the
face is that person then remove uh held
you know they're free too to punch the
person in the face so if somebody's
going to say OB seen awful things to
somebody and they punch him in the face
I think fair is
fair is well EXC I'm sorry I'm sorry
voting the other person yeah but she
sent an email and said she wasn't coming
oh she did so
um representative Reed
I I don't know exactly the answer to
what you're saying so if I'm going to
give an
example and this did this did not
necessarily it did not become an an
actual physical fight actually nothing
happened there were no words actually
exchanged but um there's a video
and it
was it's it's been like two years and it
was in DC okay and there's a video where
there was a group of people that left an
event and there was a large group of
people that in my humble opinion if
you'd watch the video I I think it'd be
quite evident that there was a lot of
harassing going on of the group that
left this event so people were you know
they had signs they had banners and they
were very much in the person's face as
the person was walking so as the person
person was just walking down the street
minding their own business trying to get
to the hotel there was a group of people
and the the group of people were jumping
back and forth in front of these this
these couple of people so basically when
people left the event they left in
staggered groups so some you know there
might have been two or three people in a
group there might have been four or five
people in the group but this particular
was only two people and there was an
entire crowd of people and they were
literally jumping back and forth and
they were screaming in their faces
asking them this question
and they just kept on repeating the
question over and over and over
um I I kept on looking at that and
saying that that that per person is
clearly antagonizing they're clearly
provoking the reaction that they wanted
in my opinion was probably to fight um I
think that they wanted the person they
were provoking to
to be physical with them right to
actually reach out and do something
because then they could have said oh
look they punched me and I didn't even
do anything right um and sometimes we
see that like we see that you know here
you're allowed to record people um but
when a person takes uh you know a selfie
stick and literally you know does this
to you that isn't T agonizing and it's
and it's incredibly rude just because
it's illegal doesn't mean that it's not
rude right but does it give you the
right to punch the person in the face
probably not you know not actually it
doesn't give you the right to punch them
in the face so I I don't exactly know
what the the sponsor's intent is um when
he was here the only thing I remember
him saying was you know if I want to
say you know you are this or this or
this if I'm and out in public I want to
be able to have the right to say that I
think you're allowed to say that
regardless I just don't think that it
means the person can punch you in the
face um yeah my my initial uh impression
when I read this was that it was for the
peaceful protesters like you said who
choose to get inside the opposition's
bubble and scream at them and yell at
them and harass them and they don't want
to be accountable for those actions they
want a a free ride to just do that we
are our free speech is protected we have
the right to Peaceful assembly but we do
not have the right to harass people and
get in their face and their bubble um
the only way I think I would support
this is if on the other side could
retaliate without any kind of um
consequence so if if they choose to
harass and intimidate somebody then
whatever reaction it drew from the other
side should be equally acceptable within
reason well I hear what you're saying I
don't so the example that I gave
you what the people that were doing the
antagonizing you know what they were
doing was considered perfectly legal I
don't think it should have been to be
honest with you they they were very much
in my opinion provoking um but at the
end of the day there was you know it was
essentially ignored
but I just I you know so I have the book
right and so the question is if you take
out that
section then everything else is still
kind of in there so how would it all you
know how would it all come together so
so B which is what he has here RSA
6442 and then B which is right here it
says directs it another person a public
place OB
seen
divisive divisive or offensive words
which are likely to provoke a violent
reaction on the part of an ordinary
person or so if you take out that then
you would just go from a right to C
right so a reads engages in fighting or
in violent
termales or threatening behavior in a
public place or to be would taken out
we'd go to C obstructs vehicular or
pedest pedestrian traffic on any public
Street or sidewalk or the entrance any
other building whatever whatever so
basically what they're saying is
everything else would still be okay to
do except if
you except you would be allowed
to say offensive words I
mean I don't know I don't first of you
can't legislate someone's feelings
exactly this is already in here um and
and I'll give an example which I shared
with um Terry that happened in nashille
and this was just two months ago where
um a young lady was going in with her
two grandchildren into City Hall and the
person coming out of City Hall resorted
to call her to nword several several
times she has no clue what made that
person do that didn't know the woman or
anything so of course the kids
frightened grabbed hold of Grandma you
know little boy was four he grabbed hold
of Grandma all right so but she went on
in city hall went into the area City
Hall where she was going to pay a bill
the woman came behind her into that
location in City Hall still calling her
the nword and the kids were petrified
someone in City Hall made the phone call
to the police and that person was
arrested and was charged yeah which I
would think would make sense as she
should be so this bill would repeal that
and give that person the right to do
that if exactly if if you take this out
they don't necessarily have that right
that person to be charged that's what
I'm saying so no I would not take that
out so you were are an agreement that
this would give people um the legal leg
to absolutely to intimidate harass and
yeah because you can't um you know like
I was speaking to one of our members and
they were saying that I'm you know words
don't heard I said excuse me we all know
that words can hurt depending on what
the words are and what you're saying to
the person and how angry or how vulgar
you are with the person it does hurt and
it could cite violence and in that case
of course you got two grandchildren with
you you're definitely not going to try
to to go back at someone but had that
been a different situation it might have
ended differently yes and with freedom
comes responsibility I mean you can't
you just can't do that and you know so
yeah I think so basically
um you know clearly we can't we can't
legislate a person's feelings right you
know you're you're responsible for your
own feelings and those those belong to
you I you know I'm not going to take
responsibility for someone else feels I
also don't think that we we also have to
live in
a civil society where we all you know
there's there's an expectation when you
walk out your door right and when you
start taking away any kind of
expectation of some normal see then you
just have Anarchy right right um and
quite honestly I I'm really trying to
figure out how everything else would go
in to play here if you took out one
whole you know paragraph but they all
seem to kind of go in with each other
and I don't I really just don't see the
point of any of it to be honest with you
I I think it's ridiculous um and I don't
know you know exactly what what the
intent of it is either right because I
you know all I remember him saying when
he was here was that you know if he
wants to be able to you know say and if
I'm not if I'm remembering correctly
what he said
was a lot of slang words and like a lot
of obscene words you know you're this
you're this what I mean I guess if you
want to say that you're going to say it
anyway and then you
know they don't want it to be they as
the the sponsor I'm saying they don't
want it to be illegal they don't want to
be able to get in trouble for such
things at the end of the day if it
escalates to where you are being
disorderly and you're causing all this
Havoc then you know it is what it is so
I I think um we're all saying the same
thing and maybe a little bit differently
but I think we're both saying the same
thing here so
abely well um we don't have a quorum so
we can't even technically vote this out
but I I do know that we can still make a
recommendation and you
know my personal recommendation just
would be to itl
Bill
okay well that's where we're at and mine
would be the same anyway so
yeah so I'm going to make an IT
recommendation
and here it's just going to be a
I'll just put that you moved it is that
okay
yep I don't know that we can officially
do it but
mys all right well that was
um a really long way
for 10 minutes
time all right this is how our weed one
went too right it was like the police
Chiefs have anything that they wanted to
say before we close anything out
or
chff
BS
I and
sherff
Es okay pretty much what we we okay all
right okay all right well um that's it
we're going to make a recommendation to
the whole committee itl it and whenever
we vote it out I I suspect that it'll go
on the consent calendar but you know we
could be wrong can't can't speak for
other people then then are right here so
all right we good good job all right I
am closing the subcommittee work session
on House Bill 10:25 FN
go
education not to
tou but you know I mean because how
about that woman that was or not even
the woman the guy that was in the
restaurant I don't know who it was with
it I Paul maybe and they followed him
into the restaurant and they were
harassing him in
the